there's no rush I don't have to panic  and throw it Lou Williams and change my  you know the way I coached these guys  because I'm getting the scoring punch  grey-thompson answers back pulls up  short jacket mega dollar paddles and the  shot clock reset to 14 late Thompson  tries again checks again  klay Thompson 6 for 6 there an pull-up  jumper looming offensive rebound  Thompson puts it in play Thompson  sizzling eerily opening parody 7 for 7  Thompson nearly throws it away jailer  guarding Durant they're off back out  Thompson corner three is good klay  Thompson has found the range already  well Durant drives Thompson relocates  Williams Helms draymond Green gets it  kicks it back out I ran extra pass  Thompson barely had in his hands had  promised no.3 unbelievable how quickly  he releases it brings it back right into  that shooting pocket McKinney well  defended by Robinson watching Robinson  he's a good tough defender Thompson  fires  klay Thompson